Resident Evil three remake has a ton of
Easter eggs and callbacks to it's 1999
counterpart more than 20 years since the
original release Capcom continues to
sneak in references not only to other
Resident Evil games but to other classic
titles as well let's explore the streets
of Raccoon City and see what we can find
after completing the game and earning
enough points you're able to unlock
Jill's classic stars uniforms eSports in
Resident Evil one shoulder pads and all
inside the Raccoon City toy shop you can
find a number of Capcom characters
including Arthur from ghosts and goblins
and Megaman although here he styled
after the North American box art from
the first few games and while not a
Capcom game these two looks suspiciously
like the Bubble Bobble dragons several
of the city's posters have returned for
the remake including aqua cure sass
buran and the Big E Band several new
movie posters have been added making
reference to Top Gun alien Terminator
and even other Capcom games speaking of
the Alien franchise coffee shop
Sigourney can be found in the opening of
the game as well making reference to the
alien actress Sigourney Weaver as you
begin your playthrough as Carlos at the
RPD you'll see zombie Brad Vickers
attacking another familiar face just
outside the front door
lieutenant Marvin Branagh after years of
wandering we finally see how Branagh
meets his fate in this scene that takes
place just before the events of Resident
Evil tubes campaign also you're still
able to visit the outdoor corridor where
Brad Vickers poster hangs sorry poster
boy sitting next to it in a locker is
Leon's future RPD uniform somebody
didn't have time to put his blues on
like in the Resident Evil 2 remake we
see what we thought might have been mr.
X's hat but upon closer inspection it
may just be in our clay sheriff's hat or
just a hat what do you think if you find
all the pieces to complete the kite
brothers railway monument puzzle you're
rewarded with the power stones
achievement making reference to of
course the classic Capcom title in the
opening parts after Jill flees her
apartment you'll end up near a public
market resembling the one in Seattle
Washington when entering the
now-familiar West Wing of the RPD you'll
see exactly how these two officers lost
a fight to a liqueur way to help out
Carlos ever wonder what the hell
happened to the men's locker room at the
RPD and why a whole wall had been blown
up well Carlos happened when you make it
to the nest as Jill you come across a
terrifying lab full of tyrants and
hunters just waiting for their chance to
wreak havoc on Raccoon City now here's a
where kannur in your time at the RPG
Carlos makes several tongue-in-cheek
references to events and items the funny
doors Leon's awful first day and some
advice that Leon simply ignored alright
you want me to keep out I'll keep out oh
and if you're wondering the locker and
safe codes are all the same so load up a
poster outside of gun shop kendo reveals
a concerned citizen who knows a little
too much someone should be listening to
this guy in one of her nemesis
encounters Jill shouts out one of her
most famous lines from the 1999 original
stars I'll give you stars in moons
doughnuts the shredding soundtrack you
here is actually the ending to Leon's
campaign from the original Resident Evil
to a tune we missed in the removal if
you notice any other easter eggs in your
playthrough share them with us here in
the comments thanks for watching and
remember it's up to us to take out
umbrella
[Applause]
[Music]
you